morgane palmer bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france alors
pour commencer un point sur la situation
sur place puisque on a deux sons de
cloche du côté du gouvernement italien
d'un côté on a le ministère de la
défense qui dit que la situation n'est
pas dramatique qu'elle est relayée par
les médias occidentaux de façon pas tout
à fait juste et puis de l'autre on a le
premier ministre qui dit qu'il va
prendre les armes qu'est ce qu'on en
sait aujourd'hui c'est un peu flou en
rhuys et c'est flou mais je dirais que
la sémantique guerrière cadre est le
vrai ministre est assez éloquente on se
souvient que le 2 novembre dernier il
avait annoncé à l'état d'urgence sur
l'ensemble du territoire éthiopien le
même lundi dernier au sortir du conseil
a dû comité exécutif de son parti le
parti de la prospérité annoncé que hier
lundi il prendrait lui-même
la tête d'aider des forces armées
éthiopiennes au front contre les
rebelles tigre aideront donc je crois
que
toutes ces annonces ne sont pas des
annonces fortuite surtout le nom de la
riche d'un prix nobel de la paix
notamment celui de 2010 vous ne lisiez
début novembre l'état d'urgence avait
été déclaré par le gouvernement
éthiopien les autorités avaient alors de
demander aux habitants notamment
d'addis-abeba de se préparer à défendre
la ville est-ce que l'armée éthiopienne
jusque là a pu compter sur la population
ou alors finalement le peuple est assez
divisés
bon on peut pas parler de deux divisions
parce que aujourd'hui les rebelles c'est
qu'ils les rebelles viennent de la
région du tigré ses 6 % de la population
de l'étude clients ça il faut le savoir
donc 6 % qui avait quand même réussi à
marcher sur addis abeba en 1991 ab non
donc le tps au pouvoir avec neil à jenna
oui
donc c'est dire que on ne peut pas
sous-estimer même si sur le plan
numérique et sur le plan de la
démographie c'est une frange minoritaire
ne peut pas seul estimer leur capacité
de nuisance
qu'
on ne peut pas dire aussi au même moment
que que les quais les forces sont
réparties à parts égales parce que deux
côtés nous en 6 % de la population même
si ils sont appuyés aujourd'hui par des
rebelles propos
tribus dont tu es originaire d'ailleurs
le tri des ministres actuels habillage
est en tout cas une situation qui
inquiète la communauté internationale
washington a prévenu un lit ce cas-là de
risque de rendre vains les progrès
diplomatique l'émissaire américain était
d'ailleurs en ethiopie la semaine passée
1 la diplomatie de la communauté
internationale finalement elle n'a rien
donné ces dernières semaines
non et quand vous dites comme de
tendance est nationale vous faites bien
de le dire parce qu'on a vu à l'ancien
président le second obasanjo du nigeria
envoyé spécial de l'union africaine
horde à vue l'émissaire américain
sleiman et même la semaine dernière
anthony blinken les secrétaires d'état
américain lors de son passage dans la
zone qui avait appelé de ses voeux une
pacification de la situation à ce que
doit savoir c'est que l'ethiopie à une
place centrale dans cette zone est
aujourd'hui une implosion de l'ethiopie
pourrait entraîner un désastre dans
toute cette région de l'est east african
donc pour l'instant la diplomatie d'un
produit en tout cas la diplomatie des
déclarations nous espérons que la manse
peut-être des mesures coercitives
prompt à ménerbes plus d'intelligence
les différents belligérants
c'est calme aux gouvernements
légitimement élus
qui subi
l'agression sur politique volonté de
cession d'une partie de son de son
territoire
donc washington à qui s'expriment et qui
tentent de se positionner en tant que
médiateur on sait aussi que que la
russie
et l'ethiopie ont des relations ils
avaient ils ont signé des accords visant
à renforcer ses relations en juillet
dernier comment est-ce que la russie à
l'eau observe cette guerre civile qui en
train de se jouer
pour l'instant t elle assez timide on
entendu
je crois que la diplomatie russe est
très pragmatique elle est agissante que
de magnet redresser n'a pas des
démocraties un spécialement à exporter
en afrique comme c'est le cas des
locales et des partenaires traditionnels
de penelope bon je parlais tout à
l'heure de coercition on peut noter
quand même que des mesures en ce sens
ont commencé puisqu'on a vu
que les turcs qui étaient suspendues du
dispositif à boire par les américains
mais il est quand même important nous
téléspectateurs qui regardent de
comprendre à quoi
quel est le sens demain existentielle du
conflit auquel on assiste aujourd'hui le
tplf qui est donc le mouvement qui tient
et addis abeba au tigre est aidé en 75
sur les décombres de l'ethiopie abrial
de beille l'acier mais d'entrée de jeu
ils n'ont pas caché leur volonté de
sécession créer une banque publique
indépendante du tigre et c'est très
important de le savoir même si par la
suite ils ont dû évoluer sur leurs
positions en intégrant de l'option armée
de comptoir qui les ont amenés à prendre
le pouvoir en 81 11 avec abs et daoui
donc la situation en ethiopie est une
situation qui est empreinte de beaucoup
de subtilité sachant que chacun des deux
camps belligérants à ses alliés le
gouvernement éthiopien avec l'erythrée
qui avait essayé de prendre un pan
sandwich aînés les tigres rien il est
tiré avec la tribu rebelles au mot grâce
à laquelle d'ailleurs ils ont fait des
grandes avancez géographique quand on
parle de 200 km de la capitale c'est
parce que la tribu rom aujourd'hui les
concentrés dans ce pour vous la capitale
addis abeba est ce que cette guerre
civile elle peut se transformer en un
conflit régional et déstabiliser même
les puissances au delà
oui
aujourd'hui on parle de 2 millions déjà
2 millions de déplacés de guerre toutes
les plaies tous ceux qui habitent dans
cette zone du tigre et qui de tristes et
de triste mémoire puisqu'on souvient que
la famine en ethiopie dans les années 80
c'est principalement cette région qui
avait été frappée aujourd'hui on a un
rôle est de la situation puisque avec
l'empêchement par les autorités d'addis
abeba de de faire acheminer les aides
alimentaires on parle d'une femme indaba
qui vaut le déplacement a crû de
population vers les pays riverains
soudan notamment ce qui est une source
de tension aujourd'hui en télé entre les
deux pays je suis donc qui lui-même
n'est pas stable puisqu'il vit
aujourd'hui une situation de perte d'une
terrine donc et l'ethiopie déstabiliser
ne soit pas sans conséquences pour tous
ces pays
dans son pourtour sachant que il partage
une frontière avec le soudan qui lui
même ouvert 7/7 pays frontaliers voyons
tout petit peu ce que ça peut engendrer
des stats en tout cas des conséquences
aussi pour les relations avec la france
puisqu'un accord de militaires et a été
suspendu or il avait été signé il ya
deux ans où emmanuel macron quelle
conséquence
de graves conséquences parce que qui dit
qu'on celui dit en quelque sorte
cessation de l'économie ou au
ralentissement de l'économie donc est
l'ethiopie qu'il est plus éligible aux
accords de la bo sera certainement
porter en quoi à l'économie ces accords
avec la france qui est un partenaire
aussi privé réglées topi tout ça ce ne
sont pas de nouvelles qui sont de nature
à assurer sachant que si on ajoute à
tension politique au conflit armé qui
alla beau jour d'hui une tension sur le
donc d'économies comme c'est le cas dans
des bars au risque d'aller d'aggravation
en intervention aujourd'hui la
diplomatie doit cesser d'être parlant
devenir réellement agissante bien qu'il
s'agisse d'un conflit qui concerne
merci beaucoup morgan palmer pour votre
éclairage ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes journaliste
consultant en intelligence stratégique